en este vídeo quiero mostrarte cómo
podemos convertir decimales que se
repiten en fracciones así que digamos
vamos a empezar escribiendo un den y un
decimal que se repite digamos que
tenemos el número 0.7 y aquí vamos a
decir que se repite el 7 en esta barrita
que se pone arriba del 7 no no es otra
cosa más que decir que el 7 se repite
por siempre entonces vamos a poner 777
otros 7 y así podemos continuar por el
resto de la eternidad pero como quiero
hacer un vídeo más o menos corto pues no
voy a seguir todo aún de término una
eternidad así que vamos a dejarlo
expresado de esta forma y el truco fue
fantástico para resolver este tipo de
problemas es expresar este número como
si fuera una variable entonces a este
vamos a llamarle que es la variable x
muy bien entonces qué es lo que vamos a
hacer vamos a fijarnos en qué pasa si
multiplicamos a x por 10
entonces vamos a multiplicar a 10 x 10
veces entonces fijémonos en qué es lo
que nos da
si nosotros multiplicamos un número por
10 lo que pasa es que el punto decimal
se recorre a la derecha una posición
verdad entonces esto nos queda como
7.777 y como aquí se repetían una
infinidad de veces el 7 pues aquí se
queda como 7.777 777 y así sucesivamente
o lo que es lo mismo expresando lo con
barritas esto es 7.7 barrita muy bien
entonces el truco aquí va a ser lo
siguiente déjenme déjenme reescribir
éstos pero poniéndolos en el orden que
me interesa voy a escribir 10 x 10 x es
igual a 7.7 barra que es 7.777 7
y así sucesivamente y ahora lo que voy a
hacer es restarle x vamos a restar x ok
y restar x restar 0.7 barra o restar 0.7
777 etcétera muy bien y ahora por qué
porque hice esto de restar porque fue
que hice esto perdón de restar fue
porque yo lo que quiero es cancelar
estos 7 es que se repiten mira si nos
damos cuenta al restar 10 x menos x lo
que nos queda acá al menos del lado
izquierdo son 9 x ok pero por otro lado
aquí este 7 se cancela con este este con
este este con necesitadas cuenta todos
los 7 se cancelan y lo único que me
queda es 7 menos 0 que es 7 y lo mismo
pasa de este lado verdad 7 digamos
podemos decir que los siete barras se
cancelan y tenemos 7 menos 0 que es 7 y
esto está fantástico porque x era el
número que yo quería expresar en
fracción y ahora ya sé que no
a veces x es 7 entonces si dividimos en
todos lados entre 9 lo que tengo es que
x mi número es 7 sobre 9 muy bien y
entonces ya escribí este decimal que se
repite muchas veces como una fracción
vamos a hacer un ejemplo más pero vamos
a dejar esto aquí para que nos sirva de
base para ver cómo resolver digamos que
tenemos ahora el número y de una vez le
pongo su variable x digamos que es 1.2 y
el 2 se repite es decir esto es 1.222 y
se repite una infinidad de veces
entonces el mismo truco vamos a
multiplicar por 10
multipliquemos este número por 10 y
entonces que es lo que nos queda el el
punto decimal se recorre a la derecha y
nos queda 12.222 y así sucesivamente o
lo que es lo mismo 12.2 barra muy bien
entonces si si pongo este número de
abajo para arrestarlo
digamos solo lo estoy copiando
y ahí está copiado y ahora lo restamos
los restamos vamos a arrestarlo y aquí
nos queda 9 x
acan se cancelan los dos barras y me
queda 12 menos uno es 11 muy bien o acá
que es lo mismo verlo acá verdad los dos
se van cancelando y me queda 11
entonces si dividimos todo entre 9
y si dividimos entre 9 nos queda que x
es igual a 11 novenos y ahí ya tenemos
dos ejemplos de cómo resolver este tipo
de problemas